we will return to that story shortly but
also we're looking at day two of the
74th session of the UN General Assembly
and Iran's leader Hassan rouhani is
slated to address world leaders at the
general debate shortly it's promised to
lay out a new plan for security in the
Gulf one that excludes the United States
tension between the u.s. and Iran have
increased after recent attacks on two
major oil facilities in Saudi Arabia
Washington says Iran was behind the
attacks Tehran denied that of course
leaders are pushing for a meeting
between Trump and rouhani but iran's
Foreign Minister has just said there is
zero chance of that earlier Iran joined
the remaining members of the 2015
nuclear deal they all reaffirmed their
commitment to salvaging the deal off we
go to New York now here is president
Hassan rouhani approaching the podium in
the General Assembly at the United
Nations smiied rahmani raheem the hymn
of God most compassionate the most
merciful may blessings and praise be
upon the Prophet Mohammad mr. president
I would like to congratulate your
dessert election as the president of the
74th General Assembly of the United
Nations and wish you success and good
luck for your excellency and the
Honorable Secretary General at the
outset I would like to commemorate the
freedom seeking movement Hussein peace
be upon him and pay homage to all the
freedom seekers of the world who do not
bow to oppression and aggression and
tolerate all the hardship of the
struggle for rights as well as to the
spirits of all the oppressed martyrs of
strikes and bombardments in Yemen Syria
occupied Palestine Afghanistan and other
countries of the world including Iraq
ladies and gentlemen the Middle East is
burning in the flames of war bloodshed
aggression occupation and religious and
sectarian fanaticism and extremism and
under such circumstances the suppressive
people of Palestine are the biggest
victims discrimination appropriation of
lands settlement expansions and killings
continue to be practiced against the
Palestinians the u.s. stands i inist
imposed plans such as the deal of the
century
recognizing battle Masada's as the
capital of the zionist regime and the
accession of the Syrian Golan to the
occupied territories are certainly
doomed against the u.s. destructive
plans the Islamic Republic of Iran's of
regional and international assistance
and cooperation on security and
counterterrorism have been so much
decisive the clear example of such an
approach is our cooperation with Russia
and Turkey within the Astana format on
the Syrian crisis and our peace proposal
for Yemen in view of our
of cooperation with a special invoice of
the secretary-general of the United
Nations as well as our efforts to
facilitate reconciliation thoughts among
the Yemen parties with the four European
countries which resulted in the
conclusion of the Stockholm peace accord
on her data port distinguished
participants I hail from a country that
has resisted the most merciless economic
terrorism and has defended its rights to
independence and science and technology
development the US government while
imposing extraterritorial sanctions and
threats against other nations has made a
lot of efforts to deprive Iran from the
advantages of participating in the
global economy and has resorted to
international piracy by misusing the
international banking system we Iranian
have been the pioneers of freedom
seeking movements in the region while
seeking peace and progress for our
nation as well as our neighbors and we
have never surrendered to foreign
aggression and imposition we cannot
believe the invitation to negotiation of
people who claim
to have applied the harshest sanctions
of history against the dignity and
prosperity of our nation how someone can
believe that the silent killing of a
great nation and pressure on the life of
83 million Iranians particularly women
and children are welcomed by the
American government officials who pride
themselves on such pressures and exploit
sanctions in an addictive manner against
a spectrum of countries such as Iran
Venezuela Cuba China and Russia the
Iranian nation will never ever forget
and forgive these crimes and these
criminals ladies and gentlemen the
attitude the incumbent US government
towards the nuclear deal or the jcpoa
not only violates the provisions of the
United Nations Security Council
resolution 2231 but also constitutes a
breach of the sovereignty and political
and economic independence of all of the
world's countries in spite of the
American withdrawal from the jcpoa and
for one year Iran remained fully
faithful to all of its nuclear
commitments in accordance with the jcpoa
out of respect for the Security Council
resolution we provided Europe with the
opportunity to fulfill its 11
commitments made to compensate for the
US withdrawal however unfortunately
we only heard beautiful words while
witnessing no effective measures it has
now become clear for all that the United
States turns its turns back to its
commitments and Europe is unable and
incapable of fulfilling its commitments
we even adopted a step-by-step approach
in implementing paragraphs 26 and 36 of
the jcpoa and we remain committed to our
promises in the deal
however our patience has a limit when
the u.s. does not respect the United
Nations Security Council resolutions and
when Europe displays inability the only
way shall be to rely on national dignity
pride and strength they call us to
negotiations while they run away from
treaties and deals we negotiated with
the incumbent US government on the 5+1
negotiating table however they failed to
honor the commitment made by their
predecessor on behalf of my nation and
state I would like to announce that our
response to any negotiation under
sanctions is negative the government and
people of Iran have remained steadfast
against the harshest sanctions in the
past one and a half years and will never
negotiate with an enemy that seeks to
make Iran surrender with the weapon of
poverty pressure and sanctions if you
require a positive answer
and as declared by the leader of the
Islamic Revolution the only way for
talks to begin is to return to
commitments and compliance if you are
sensitive to the name of jcpoa well then
you can return to its framework and
abide by the United Nations Security
Council resolution 2231 stop the
sanctions so as to open the way for the
start of negotiations I would like to
make it crystal clear if you are
satisfied with the minimums
we will also convince ourselves with the
minimums either for you or for us the
jcpoa was a minimum for you and for us
however if you wish more if you require
more you should also give and pay more
if you stand on your word that you only
have one demand for Iran ie non
production and non utilization of
nuclear weapons then it's it could
easily be attained in view of the IAEA
supervision and more importantly with
the fatwa of the Iranian leader instead
of a show of negotiations you shall
return to the reality of negotiations
memorial photos are the last station of
negotiations not the first one ladies
and gentlemen we in Iran despite all of
the obstructions created by the unit US
government are keeping on the path of
economic and social growth and
prosperity
Iran's economy in 2017 registered the
highest economic growth rate in the
world and today despite fluctuations
emanating from foreign interference in
the past one and a half years we have
returned to the track of growth and
stability
Iran's gross domestic product - oil has
become positive again in recent months
and the trade balance of the country
remains positive distinguished
participants the security doctrine of
the Islamic Republic of Iran is based on
the maintenance of peace and stability
in the Persian Gulf and providing
freedom of navigation and safety of
movement in the Strait of Hormuz the
recent incidents have seriously
endangered such security security and
peace in the Persian Gulf Sea of Oman
and the Strait of Hormuz could be
provided with the participation of the
countries of the region and the free
flow of oil and other energy resources
could be guaranteed provided that we
consider security as an umbrella in all
areas for all of the countries upon the
historical responsibility of my country
in maintaining security peace stability
and progress in the Persian Gulf region
and Strait of Hormuz I should like to
invite all the countries directly
affected by the developments in the
Persian Gulf and the Strait of Hormuz to
the coalition of hope
meaning foremost peace endeavor the goal
of the Coalition for hope is to promote
peace stability progress and welfare for
all of the residents of the Strait of
hermos region and enhance mutual
understanding and peaceful and friendly
relations amongst them this initiative
includes various venues for cooperation
such as the collective supply of energy
security freedom of navigation and free
transfer of oil and other resources to
and from the Strait of Hormuz and beyond
the Coalition for Hope is based on
important principles such as compliance
with the goals and principles of the
United Nations mutual respect equal
footing dialogue and understanding
respect for territorial integrity and
sovereignty inviolability of
international borders peaceful
settlement of all differences and more
importantly two fundamental principles
of non-aggression and non-interference
in the domestic affairs of each other
the presence of the United Nations seems
necessary for the creation of an
international umbrella in support of the
coalition of Hope the Minister of
Foreign Affairs of the Islamic Republic
of Iran shall provide more details of
the coalition of hope to the beneficiary
States ladies and gentlemen
formation of any security coalition an
initiative under any title in the region
with the centrality and command of
foreign forces is a clear example of
interference in the affairs of the
region the securitization of navigation
is in contravention to the right to free
navigation and the right to development
em and would escalate tensions and more
complication of conditions an increase
of mistrust in the region while
jeopardizing regional peace security and
stability the security of our region
shall be provided when American troops
pullout security shall not be supplied
with American weapons and intervention
the United States after 18 years has
failed to reduce acts of terrorism
however the Islamic Republic of Iran
managed to terminate the scourge of -
with the assistance of neighboring
nations and governments the ultimate way
towards peace and security in the Middle
East passes through inward democracy and
outward diplomacy security cannot be
purchased or supplied by foreign
governments the peace security and
independence of our neighbors is the
peace security and independence of us
America is not our neighbor this is the
Islamic Republic of Iran which neighbors
you and we have been long taught that
neighbor comes first
then comes the house
in the event of an incident you and we
shall remain alone we are neighbors with
each other and not with the United
States the United States is located here
not in the Middle East the United States
is not the advocate of any nation
neither is the guardian of any state in
fact states do not delegate power to
attorney to other states and do not give
custodianship to others if the flames of
the fire of Yemen have spread today to
hijos the warmonger should be sought and
punished
rather than levelling allegations and
grudge against the innocent the security
of Saudi Arabia shall be guaranteed with
the termination of aggression to Yemen
rather than by inviting foreigners we
are ready to spend our national strength
and regional credibility and
international authority the solution for
peace in the Arabian Peninsula security
in the Persian Gulf and stability in the
Middle East should be sought inside the
region rather than outside of it the
issues of the region are bigger and more
important than the United States is able
to resolve the United States has failed
to resolve the issue in Afghanistan Iraq
and Syria and has been the supporter of
extremism Taliban ISM and - ISM such a
government is clearly unable to resolve
more sophisticated issues of today
distinguished colleagues
our region is on the edge of collapse as
a single blunder can fuel a big fire we
shall not tolerate the provocative
intervention of foreigners we shall
respond decisively and strongly to any
sort of transgression - and violation of
our security and territorial integrity
however the alternative improper
solution for us is to strengthen
consolidation among all the nations with
common interests in the Persian Gulf and
the hormones region this is the message
of the Iranian nation let's invest on
hope towards a better future rather than
in war and violence let's return to
justice to peace to law commitment and
promise and finally to the negotiating
table I thank you all for your attention
Iran's president Hassan rouhani
addressing the United Nations General
Assembly in New York a speech of two
very different tones he spoke a lot
about peace about negotiating about the
idea of a coalition of Hope which we'll
discuss in a moment but then also very
much pointing the finger at the United
States it is not an advocate or guardian
of any other country and that we should
respond decisively to any violation of
our integrity we have got to
correspondence looking at this one's own
bus Rafi as in Tehran we'll be with you
shortly
saying but I'm starting with our
diplomatic editor James BAE's at the
United Nations as I said James it was I
felt there were two different tones
coming out of that entire speech what
was the the biggest line that you
coming up well I think there are a
number of important lines there towards
the end are reaching is on the edge of
collapse a single blunder could fuel a
big fire I don't think there are many
people who would disagree with the
severity of the situation in the Middle
East and particularly the Gulf at this
stage but clearly President rouhani has
a different view on what to do about the
situation he came up I think with two
important statements one about his new
initiative I'll come to that in a moment
but two about sitting down with
President Trump and the Iran nuclear
deal he made it quite clear his
conditions for doing so he said that the
u.s. had to accept the existing deal
because he said it was binding
international law resolution 2231 of the
UN Security Council he said - that the
sanctions must be lifted then if all of
that is done then then they could sit
down with the US and potentially have
further negotiations about further
issues now clearly the US does not like
the Iran deal it doesn't want to accept
the Iran deal and I don't think those
conditions would be acceptable to the US
so we do have a problem here and I think
it now is impossible to see a meeting
between President Trump and President
rouhani here in New York remember just a
few weeks ago at the g7 summit in
Barretts it had seemed like a
possibility if a slim one because the
French were working so hard to mediate
between the two sides remember President
rouhani is not gonna be here much longer
and President Trump is giving his final
news conference in just a few hours time
and then be heading from New York back
to Washington with this issue but also
lots of domestic issues on his mind
the other important thing of the speech
was that initiative we'd heard about it
before we've been getting details
fleshed out all week from the Iranians
they say this is an important piece
initiative that would bring in all the
countries of the Gulf area all of those
that border the Gulf would be invite
under a UN umbrella to discuss all of
the problems in the region issues like
navigation in the region along that most
important waterway of the straits of
hormuz where so much of the world's oil
passes that's certainly a proposal that
is not going to particularly upset some
members of the international community
for example Russia current president of
the UN Security Council Russia has come
up with a very similar proposal I've
even heard the UK at various points
saying that maybe there is some merit in
looking at an old Security Council
resolution that suggests something
similar going back to the end of the
iran-iraq war and even the UN
secretary-general has suggested
something a bit like the Helsinki
process at the end of the Cold War bring
you all the regional elements together
it's worth me telling you that a
high-level source in the UN Secretariat
says when the secretary-general floated
that idea Iran accepted it straight away
and said yes we're on board with this
Saudi Arabia when they were approached
with it rejected it's straight out of
hand great analysis from our diplomatic
editor James BAE's at the UN in New York
thank you